you know it's like when the fresh prince
calls like you you take the you take the
meeting right
i never like aspired to write a memoir
or ghostwrite or write for a celebrity
or anything but i think for me it was it
was super interesting just because what
i get really excited about and really
interested in is
is just human psychology it's just it's
why do people do the things that they do
why do they what makes them tick
to me it's just he's like one of the
most interesting
case studies in the world and so for me
it was just a pure joy to kind of get to
know
not just him but like kind of what makes
him tick his personality where he comes
from the failures that he's been through
how he reacted to those failures we had
a good chemistry i think our skills
balance each other out really well like
he's always super like happy-go-lucky
and i'm just a cynical bastard i just
want to like live in the darkness um and
so when we came together it was actually
a really nice balance
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast thank you so much for joining
i am really really excited about the
guest today maybe you've heard of him
his name is mark manson he is an author
he also started off in blogging so he's
a big blogger but his books um have sold
over 13 million copies uh the two big
ones are
the subtle art of not giving a [ __ ] and
the other one is everything is [ __ ] a
story about hope uh he's also maybe
you've seen also written will smith's
book called will a really authentic guy
in digging into
his life and as he shares
in the episode more comfortable sharing
his real-life scenarios than coming up
with um fictitious story which we talk
about quite late in the episode about
kind of things that he's inspired to to
do moving forward but you know a lot of
this was just talking about you know his
evolution as a person and where he's at
and just kind of the shift that he's
made on his own and the things that get
him excited now
but of course we definitely got into um
his main topics and of course the main
one being relationships he just had some
really great nuggets of
information and perspectives simple
one-sentence
statements that are like wow about
relationships and the way that it should
go and you know the sort of romanticism
of a relationship but then also looking
at what real-life relationships look
like
and and being realistic about that and
then of course the whole idea of just
taking accountability and looking at
yourself and and really unpacking all
those patterns that you see emerging in
your relationships so that you can step
into the one that you want and and be
able to show up fully and let someone
see you fully which is part of the game
if you like this episode and other
episodes that you've heard please click
on the subscribe button to get the
notifications when another one's out how
are you
i'm great how are you doing nice to meet
you nice to meet you i'm very excited
about this i've been reading all of your
many many instagram inspirational posts
for a long time
cool did you post something that you
weren't going to do that anymore
um
i i'm like
see it's like my half-assed retirement
um
where it's
how are you
i'm 37. i'm 59 and i'm like just
starting companies again come on come on
mark it's valuable we need it i i i know
well so the thing i wrote a newsletter
in
december saying that like
i'm going to kind of gradually
phase a lot of kind of the personal
development content out over the next
year or two um so it's not like i'm
stopping it's just i'm gonna kind of
slow down like i've been grinding at
this for
13 years
um
and at a certain point you just start
repeating yourself and um
so
there will still be content i've got a
great team behind me who's excellent at
taking things i've written and
repurposing them and putting them on
instagram and twitter and all that so
there will be content for a long time
but um just in terms of like my like
where my creative focus is um
it's gonna start kind of moving on to
other things
well that actually is a a quick and easy
early sort of pivot into
the concept that you write about what
you're dealing with and
that you know the the books and the
blog and
it's all a reflection of what you're
going through yourself
and
so
i'm curious then what it is that you're
into now and what you've decided to give
a [ __ ] about now
that's new
yeah so it's funny because
you know i i kind of stumbled into this
if you want to call it that
on accident like i
was
i would describe myself as an
emotionally dysfunctional
uh
person 10 12 years ago
my relationships were disastrous i
didn't really manage myself very well um
but i loved writing and i was good at it
so i kind of like
wrote out my
therapeutic process very publicly and it
kind of took off and became very very
popular um
and that was great like it was great
because it helped me a lot it helped me
sort through all my [ __ ] um and it
helped other people too because other
people could relate and kind of follow
along or try things i was trying or
whatever
um
but then there's there's a little bit of
a like a catch 22 where like
like i'm i'm good now like i'm in a
really good spot
so if i keep writing about this same
stuff either
a it doesn't feel authentic and then b
it kind of feels weird like you know if
my marriage is great and
my family life is great it feels weird
to keep writing about like
[ __ ] up toxic relationships all the
time like that doesn't right well you
you're writing about where you're at so
it's yeah a wonderful like
congratulations to be in a place where
you're prepared to move on and you're
not processing yourself some of those
you know topics that you dive into and
you know toxic relationships and all the
things that go along with being a human
and you're kind of evolving but there's
is there somewhere you're evolving to
that's grabbing you right now that's
different or is it is it like a whole
different space or or can we just
benefit from your new issues
[Laughter]
i hope i hope everybody can benefit from
my new issues um yeah it's funny i'm i'm
in a period where i don't know what's
next right so
um
there are other areas of my life that i
kind of want to focus on you know i i am
starting to get older so i want to focus
on health a lot like i haven't
treated my body the best the last 20
years
so i kind of want to you know i want to
focus on health i want to focus on
family
i am getting more interested in in kind
of conventional businesses you mentioned
that you're starting up a bunch of
businesses so like that's an area that
is catching my interest a little bit
more
um
but yeah we'll see like i've kind of set
aside 2022 in my mind as like
just an exploratory ear of oh and that's
um
you know focusing on myself again i'm
like i'm coming out of like kind of this
insane sprint i did like four books in
six years and a bunch of these projects
and i kept the web
website going and the blog going and
you know i'm asking the same question
you're asking it's like what's next like
what's the next thing so
let me just reverse psychoanalyze you um
so if values being something that you
talk about a lot and that leads your
emotions which is essentially
your baseline and how you're feeling and
how your life really is like what do you
value then
well it's interesting because i think
you know values evolve throughout your
life
totally totally yeah and
some you know there are certain things
that
i didn't give too many [ __ ] about
before and now i'm starting to give more
[ __ ] um
you know health is kind of the easy
example there um
i like actually want to go to bed
by like i'm becoming an old man i'm like
want to be in bed by 10 you know i get
cranky if i'm not and it's just i feel
like my my 27 year old self would be
horrified if he saw what what i've
become um but like the 10 to 6 club
and i didn't choose to be here just
my biological clock just started doing
it uh much to my horror but um
but like
it's
i would say you know
it's an interesting thing and i imagine
you've been through some similar
experiences in your own journey where
it's like
when you love when you start leveling up
in your life like when you when you like
hit some big benchmarks
you hit some big success you gain a
platform you get a bunch of money
um
the questions start changing you know
and it's
it starts to become much much less of
like
you know oh [ __ ] what do i have to do to
make it and it becomes much more of like
okay how can i give back or
you know what's my legacy going to be um
or
you know how do i actually want to be
remembered um
or what are what are the opportunities
that i now have that i didn't have say
five ten years ago and so
i think a lot of this is kind of that
transition as well um i mean i i think
i'll always write and
i i like writing books but
um
there's a lot of space
in between the writing like there's a
lot of
just time to do other things and to work
on other things and um
and so that's kind of like what i'm
trying to figure out at the moment is
that where writing will smith's book
came in where it was just kind of this
sort of trail off of like your own
content into someone else's have you
written other people's books i don't
know
no just his
that's really cool i mean was that part
of it was just kind of like a different
project that got you out of your space
and into someone else's well first of
all a lot of it had to do with who he is
you know it's like when the fresh prince
calls like you you take the you take the
meeting right
i remember a hundred years ago it was
like one of his sons was turning 16 or
something like that and they're like
team reached out about me like making a
video and there's some compilation that
was going into his like video birthday
party thing and they asked and i was
like oh yeah of course like yeah yeah do
you just like make a video for some
kid's birthday for like well smith yeah
it's it's i've i never like aspired to
write a memoir or ghostwrite or write
for a celebrity or anything but yeah
when it's him it's like all right you go
you go talk to him and
you know it was a great project i think
for me it was it was super interesting
just because what i get really excited
about and really interested in is is
just human psychology it's just it's why
do people do the things that they do why
do they what makes them tick
um why do we fail in certain ways and
succeed in others etc and
to me it's just he's like one of the
most interesting
case studies in the world right and uh
and so for me it was just
a pure joy to kind of get to know
not just him but like kind of what makes
him tick
his personality
um
where he comes from the failures that
he's been through how he reacted to
those failures
um
and then on top of that you know like he
and i
we had a good chemistry i think
our skills balance each other out really
well like
he's always super like happy-go-lucky
positive like almost to a point where
it's a little delusional and
um and i'm just a cynical bastard and
it just one of the titles would say that
it just want to like live in the
darkness um and so when we came together
it was actually a really nice balance
you know because it's
it
it ended up being a very fun and cool
project to kind of do together um
but yeah i mean to kind of answer your
original question of like why i took it
i mean
aside from just the project being cool
um you know subtle art blew up and
became
so successful so quickly like vastly
more successful than i ever anticipated
that there was like a little bit i think
there were there were a couple years
where uh
i guess you could probably call it
imposter syndrome a little bit of like
oh [ __ ] like
what if this is like my one thing you
know what if this never happens again
and what if this is like my one window
to like
you know
to like to make it count and and so i
just started saying yes to pretty much
anything that was you know
even remotely interesting uh
you're still doing that because you said
yes to my interview so
i'm actually not doing many interviews
anymore danica i'm super grateful yeah
no it's uh when you were a yes i was
like are you kidding me i was like are
you serious
no i mean it's it's i'm trying to back
off the last year or two i'm trying you
know i've i'm not working on a book
most my pro big projects are wrapped at
the moment i've cut i'm not doing
speaking at the moment and i've probably
cut back like 75 80 on interviews so um
so yeah it's it's uh
different seasons of a career or a life
you know that's part of life is the
seasons of life there's the micro
there's the macro you're going to have
your mini seasons within your days and
your weeks and you're going to have the
macro in your years and decades and
they're going to bring you something
different and i think giving that
permission having permission giving
yourself permission to be in those
different seasons is
um and also sucking it up when it's time
for a season that's tough is like this
is the time right when you said this is
my moment i'm gonna say yes to
everything and look where you are so you
can't argue that it didn't work before i
get into the heavier stuff that is all
about psychology because i'm super
fascinated with psychology psychology
science spirituality any of those realms
are my jam but i love psychology i'm
reading um i'm reading the book
the body keeps the score right now so
that's a great book
so anyway um do you think that maybe
there is some
effect from
will that
was this sort of happy-go-lucky
guy that rubbed off on you is there some
sort of epigenetic
um
science experiment happening with you
where you just kind of saw this other
side or it brought out a side of you
um that maybe you hadn't really
cultivated or gave enough time to
i think a little bit i wouldn't
characterize it in in those same words
i'll say this he
ended up becoming a little bit of a role
model for me um because i started
working with him like i said my career
just blown up book is
everywhere i'm getting invited on all
these tv shows and speaking events and
all this stuff and when it takes off and
people start recognizing you in the
street and and
events sell out like it starts [ __ ]
with your head a little bit and
and he was just a great role model of
like this is how you do it like he was
amazing he's amazing with his fans he's
amazing with his team he's great with
you know journalists and publicists and
everything he's got systems for
everything you know because he's just
been in this game forever definitely and
and so it was actually really useful to
be around him a lot you know because we
did a lot of interviews but there was
also just a lot of like i just kind of
tagged along and
went wherever he went and um
and so it was really really educational
and inspirational for me of like oh [ __ ]
like this is how you do it like this is
how you manage
you know
expectations of fans and this is how you
deal with the press and this is you know
when if
something shitty comes out on the
internet about you like you know this is
kind of the attitude that you should
have about it um
and so it was a real blessing in that
way for me
um it's funny because all the stuff
that's actually in the book or most of
the stuff that's in the book
um
you know it's
psychology personal development stuff
which i've been doing forever so it's
like there wasn't really
many
epiphanies for me personally
there you know from his story
um it was more like the professional
side of just seeing his professionalism
and his experience
and just how good he is at all that it's
always cool to be able to spend time
around people that um
you know live a different life no matter
what life it is you learn from learn
from ones that have an extravagant life
learn to learn from ones that have a
simple life and
the best thing you can do is take
something from that so it sounds like
you have once you get on that path of
self-development it's like i feel like
if you explain to somebody what it was
like to be on the path to
whatever you want to call it awakening
or
self-improvement development
it's it's like i feel like it's a ride
you never get off i i think of these
things in terms of skills right so it's
like we're developing emotional skills
we're developing communication skills
we're developing self-awareness as a
skill in most skills like
to develop it there's like that process
of of
unconscious incompetence conscious
incompetence
conscious
competence unconscious confidence right
like i don't know if you've seen that
grid before but it's you know to learn
anything you have to start out by
becoming aware of all the things you're
bad at
and then from there you consciously work
on improving them
but then the final step is to actually
stop thinking about it at some point
right it's like if you if you're
learning how to ski
when you first learn you have to think
about everything you're doing you have
to think about how you're placing your
feet and how you're moving down the hill
and everything but at a certain point
that thinking is actually going to make
you worse
and and to be in to be excellent at it
you actually have to stop thinking about
it
um
i lived that
i did a race car i drove a race car
you don't think about the driving yeah
you got to make that the easy part i
mean if you if you were thinking in the
car by
it's probably too late like
trying to calculate passes and people
around me and pit stops and you know oil
and fuel you know oil temperature water
temperature do we need more tape on the
grill do i need this change with the
handling track bar tire pressure what do
i need you know
all of that stuff is going on as opposed
to just driving the car so you got good
at driving your car
yes and so i think at a certain point i
think what gets under publicized in the
personal development world is that final
step to unconscious competence of like
you know at some point you shouldn't
have to think about
you know every little thing in your
relationship you shouldn't have to think
about disciplining every minute of your
day you know because at a certain point
you're actually harming yourself in that
sense
i think there is
there's kind of an under discussed
point to
to to turning it off a little bit or
just kind of going into unconscious
confidence you know driving the car
without thinking about driving the car
um but i think from a broader
perspective it's like you never want to
stop like the same principles of
you know what am i bad at what are my
goals like where do i want to get um how
do i get there how do i learn the skills
necessary to get there like that that's
a process that never stops and so it's
like
this kind of
this emotional world
uh that i've i've spent so much time in
uh i feel my i feel myself kind of you
know going into unconscious competence
but i'm sure you know whatever the next
thing whatever the next thing arises
right like let's say i decide to get
into some crazy new business or whatever
i'm gonna be terrible at it and it's
it's
it's so i have to go back and and start
that whole process again of being like
you know why am i tip why am i bad at
this how do i get better
um so in that sense it never ends
what you're saying to me sounds like re
you're just reprogramming the
subconscious for that your your
automatic systems during the day your
resp there's two parts i think that it
sounds like you know your systems are in
place to whether whether it is how you
however you deal with yourself or how
you deal with relate to other people
that you've done a really good job of
excavating that and healing that
integrating parts of yourself that were
not integrated before and also
additionally probably i think that this
shows up in triggers right like yeah so
that's like that's the other part of the
work is just identifying when you're
actually being triggered right and and
allowing that work in so
it kind of leads to the question i was
thinking of which i think is like really
kind of dives into the to the start of
this and and and really like gets into
psychology is that
do you think it's possible to
heal the aspects of yourself that are
triggered and then project on to other
people or are unhealthy perhaps an
unhealthy relationship and
an action that you take as a coping
mechanism is it possible to actually get
to all those things without
unpacking
your childhood and understanding your
relational uh
how you relate to your mom your dad your
caretakers um
traumatic events throughout your life
and i'm not talking about getting your
arm cut off but i feel like we're all
getting a little better at understanding
trauma it's just a really emotional
thing that happened to you and it
doesn't have to be big on the outside it
just feels big on the inside do you
think we can get to that without getting
to the family and getting to the roots
and the childhood and inner child stuff
i don't think so i and
i i wish i could say yes here's a
shortcut you know
here's the super secret shortcut that
heals trauma without actually having to
like dig into your past i mean
ultimately it's it's
you know the way the human brain works
is it's it's a
it's a trigger and response mechanism
right it's like it's a pattern builder
and
the earlier the earlier you go into your
life the more fundamental those patterns
are um
the more they underlie everything else
that has come since and so that's why
that it's like if you have dysfunction
somewhere in your life
and it could be anything it could be you
know struggling with anxiety it could be
relationship problems it could be
um
imposter syndrome or self-sabotage or
you know substance addiction all these
things like it's there's some
ultimately what that dysfunction is is
is a pattern
in your brain that's that's not healthy
it's not working
and uh and you need to go break that and
and
kind of realign it
and um
and generally speaking it's
you know the bigger the dysfunction the
further down
the stack of patterns you have to dig to
um and it's like
i i think
it's funny the whole like digging into
the childhood thing and and
you know figuring you know mom didn't
hug me enough or dad said this or that
like it it's
it's sometime it's not like sometimes i
do think it gets overrated i think
sometimes people do focus on it a little
bit too much like here's the funny thing
about it is that
if you if you
start kind of wallowing in in your past
and your childhood and stuff that can
actually become a new form of avoidance
for dealing with the present
there's a lot of people who
spend so much time digging through their
baggage in the past that
it's like become kind of a convenient
excuse for not dealing with whatever
problem that they have in the present so
in that sense
i think it could be overrated at times
but
at the same time it's like
it's better to spend too much time back
there than
not enough you know
ultimately
understanding yourself who you are why
you are the way you are um is such just
an important piece of knowledge for
everything you do in life
and you really can't figure that out
until you you go back and spend time
with that spend time with like how your
your family environment was what your
neighborhood was like you know the
shitty things that happened to you as a
kid um all those things matter and you
know maybe some matter
a little bit more than others or some
maybe some don't matter as much as you
thought they did or they actually matter
a lot more than you thought they did
um but ultimately it's like the value is
actually just
developing that knowledge base
of yourself becoming kind of an expert
on your own patterns and your own
uh scripts and narratives that you have
yeah i'm kind of fascinated with the
question of whether or not
we can ever truly experience someone
else objectively
or not
as in we have our own lens that we see
everything through and is it possible to
actually see someone like totally
objectively
i don't think so
which is crazy to think i mean that
should really like hit for people
that should hit that you know
i mean
you can't see someone objectively you're
seeing it through your own
the things you think like i don't know
like a stupid example and things i
always have the silliest examples for
when i learn these things because they
they they happen in the simplest of ways
but it's like somebody a friend could be
like oh my forehead's really big and i'm
like oh my god i don't even see that
like you're beautiful and that's because
i don't it's not my it's not something i
think about right so like i'm not seeing
it because it's not in me it's not
something i think about right
so um where on the other hand you know i
might see someone that's
um you know really short and since i'm
five one i'd be like oh yeah that's it
yeah that's not an example i've thought
about but it's something that would
register for me what is what are the
keys then that other people hold for us
as um
in life like how do we use them
because
we can't we also can't see ourselves
right i mean would you do you agree i
feel like that like i need other people
to see me i i think it's one of those
things where like you can be more
objective or less objective but you're
never going to be entirely objective you
know like it's it's you can get better
at it but you're never nobody's ever
going to nail it
you know it's it's ultimately
you know human perception didn't evolve
for accuracy it evolved for survival and
so the reason we have a lot of the
biases that we have the misp like the
delusions that we have the way we we
uh you know it's it's one day you look
at a person and they seem really
uh really cool and attractive and the
next day they seemed like a horrible
person even though nothing really
changed like all these little things
were kind of built into our brain
because
ultimately they had like adaptive
purposes
uh for survival for evolutionary
survival and
i think once you understand that
and understand that like okay
just because you think something's true
or or believes something is true like
doesn't necessarily make it true it kind
of frees you to start
um
questioning a lot of these things and
and trying to trying to make that effort
to be a little bit more objective or
to get a little bit closer to the truth
and i think that absolutely applies to
ourselves i mean i think everybody has
had an experience at some point where
either their perception of themselves
was completely off base
or you've had a friend before who like
can't whose perception of themselves is
completely off base and like you're just
like wow how do they not see
the reality in front of them right like
how
how warped must their perceptions be to
actually think this is true about
themselves when like me and all the
people around them can see it's not true
like i think we've all had that
experience before we've seen it in other
people and
and
it it happens in ourselves as well and
so it's kind of like
we've all got little blind spots and um
and so we have to be like
i think it's an important
process of questioning
uh where are my blind spots or like
where am i
uh
where am i not being objective and how
can i how can i be better and it's a
never-ending process because it's just
our hardware is not built to be
objective it's
it's built to be subjective why is it
why is it that it takes
sort of the mirroring aspect of nature
of being a human to
to see i don't why why do we need
someone else to see ourselves
if you look at humans as as just an
animal
we actually we we suck at most things
like if you compare us to the other apes
like we're super weak we're really slow
we can't climb we're [ __ ] yeah we
sunburned like crazy like we don't have
sonar we can't see at night
can't swim more [ __ ] like it it's
it's
if you were to like put us on paper next
to like all
most of the other like eight great apes
and and a lot of other mammals and stuff
like we're bad at we're very mediocre at
most things like the human superpower
the reason why we are
so dominant on the planet is we
developed language and social
relationships and the ability to
cooperate and
so there's like a very
fundamental like arguably the most
fundamental
piece of our psychology is that we find
meaning in relationships and
um
and so we're just very
primally driven
to
uh want and experience intimacy and
love and camaraderie and and have a
supportive network around us like it's
it's if you look at all the data on
well-being and
happiness and longevity it's like
it's relationships are always first and
then everything else is like distant
second third fourth and um
and so i think it's just
it's a it's like the most fundamental
component of our
uh psychological well-being and
a huge part of that is
we're constantly
negotiating
our sense of identity in our sense of
self like we're never quite sure who we
are you know it's like you know okay
well i've written some books but like am
i really an author or did i just get
lucky a couple of times you know or like
does that mean i have to write books
again or does that mean that's the only
thing i am or maybe i want to be
something else you know so there's this
constant like discovery process that's
happening within ourselves we like and
need for other people around us to to
kind of validate those discoveries or to
challenge those discoveries to kind of
push back on them or or
perhaps even discover things about us
for us you know things that we can't see
in ourselves they see in us and this is
this is what intimacy is this is what
you know it's when you feel seen when
you feel like oh my god this person gets
me they know who i am like that's that
feeling of comfort and security and
intimacy is like that's
it's it's when your discovery of
yourself matches somebody else's
perception of you and um wait say that
again say that again nice and slow
so i mean this is what intimacy is when
your discovery of yourself or your
perception of yourself is matched by
somebody who sees you the same way
and
it's an incredibly profound and
emotional experience for all of us and
it's what what binds us together you
know all these crazy emotions that we
all struggle to deal with like
ultimately that a lot of their purpose
is
to make us all
attached to one another feel attached to
one another and want to sacrifice and
help one another and
that's what makes our species so
successful but then i have to ask
why are relationships so hard this is
not an uncommon question for you i would
watch every single interview you've ever
done
and every single day that you've
struggled you're like why is this so
hard i at least ask that to myself every
single day why are relationships so hard
um and these can be you know the
romantic ones are probably kind of what
i'm most curious about but this applies
to
family and children as well like the
closest one closest people to us it's
you know in our human nature to be in
community and and have love and
relationships yet it's the thing that we
almost have the most resistance around
yeah and i think it's for the exact same
reason because you know the the more
exposed your identity is to somebody the
more they have an ability to hurt you
emotionally
because you know if intimacy is somebody
seeing you the way you see yourself
then that person turning around and
being like no no you're actually a piece
of [ __ ] like that hurts 10 times as much
and especially if you
come from a background a family history
where people are not you know
it's not healthy like there's not a
healthy intimacy in your family
environment when you're young
you develop all sorts of patterns and
triggers around intimacy that
that cause more pain
and so this is why it's like you know
maybe you go to work and your co-worker
kind of makes a joke of like oh you're
so messy you should clean your desk and
you're like ha ha you know screw you but
then you go home
and your partner comes home and is like
wow you're so messy you should clean up
your mess and you just [ __ ] explode
like it's just because it it's they have
deeper access
to you in terms of
um how you see yourself you know your
co-worker's just a co-worker it's like
who cares what he thinks
but when it's your partner and they've
seen all of you and they know all of you
and they have access to all of you at
all times and then they say something
that and especially if that something
has a long history of causing you pain
in your life
um
it can just set you off people run
that's why
right i'm just thinking of real life
scenarios in my own head and like you
say something to someone and it isn't
even meant to be harmful but there's
some there's truth there and it's like
if there's the ego comes in and is like
oh hell no not having that
well yeah and then it's fight fight or
flight you know so it's either
[ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ] you know
let's get into it or it's like all right
i'm out of here and then and then that
behavior kind of perpetuates itself
right so what's the lesson like if
that's if that's something that's
happening for someone that's listening
like what is the lesson if somebody does
something and they're like oh no but he
was a dick or like she was way out of
line like you know that [ __ ] right like
i mean there could be a million
scenarios people are thinking of so what
what what is the course of action when
you have that kind of a response to
something because you truly like in your
soul feel like they did something wrong
and and they and they might not be right
but like what do you do next because you
you work through it with them or you go
work through it with the next person
right
um
well it's
i mean two
there's kind of like a process on two
levels so one is an
internal process with yourself so it's
like until you understand your own
internal triggers and your own patterns
and
understand of like oh wow
i get irrationally upset in this
situation that's bad right it's like
it's that's a very very important piece
of information to know about yourself
because generally you're asking people
but you're asking people to know about
themselves before they have the
information like it's the whole like i
can't know myself
it's a chicken and the egg thing right
so it's it's like
you know you your your first
relationship is a [ __ ] disaster but
you kind of need that disaster
because you learn all this stuff about
yourself like you learn
you know you you learn like oh i'm
really bad in these situations or i i'm
really sensitive about this topic or i i
struggle a lot with jealousy or anger or
whatever and then you get into that next
relationship and you're able to kind of
see like okay
[Applause]
the partners change but this the same
problem is happening so maybe it's me
you know and
and then maybe that one fails you get to
another relationship and it keeps
happening you're like okay now it's
definitely me like now this is
definitely
this is definitely my fault i don't know
what i'm doing like that in my life
so yeah yeah you're like i don't know
what you're talking about
really well
um
so there's kind of this process you know
because all of us you know when we get
emotionally triggered our first
assumption is that we're right you know
it's like nobody nobody actually stops
like mid
hissy fit and thinks to themselves am i
having a hissy fit right now like it's
just
you're just like full explode mode and
you have to kind of go back after the
fact and be like wait a second i just
like blew up over something really
really stupid
um
why did i do that you know where does
this come from and this is where therapy
helps a lot you know because it's
the therapist kind of facilitates your
ability to start digging into
all these patterns and triggers and
stuff and um
so so the first process is an internal
one it's like you have to understand
yourself otherwise you know
it doesn't matter how awesome your
partner is like there's no chance you
know it's like if you're just
blowing up left and right you know
dropping bombs everywhere
you can't complain that the house is on
fire like it's it's just until you
figure out how to stop doing that
yourself like there's not really a
chance to
to make the relationship healthy
and conversely it's like if you're with
a partner who hasn't figured that stuff
out about themselves
there's not really like you can't force
somebody
to figure out their own [ __ ] like you
can support them you can encourage them
you can be like hey
uh maybe you want to go to therapy you
know but like you can't you can't sit
there and fix their problems for them
and a lot of people get caught in that
trap because it's easier it's easy to
see the triggers and the patterns in in
somebody else it's hard to see it in
yourself um so you need both people to
have spent done the work to kind of see
it in themselves that's like step one
you've got two people who are able to do
that with themselves step two is that
they're able to communicate those things
in in a way that's not blaming or
demeaning or judgmental or whatever it's
like it's very and this this is
you know it's communication skills it's
a type of communication skill it takes
practice you know but it's basically
like learning how to okay i'm blowing up
i'm irrational in these situations i
need my partner to know
that i've got like baggage in this area
or that this is just a weird thing that
sets me off you know and so your partner
can understand that and kind of work
with you on it
and so and then from there it's just
kind of this
you become a team you know and it's like
both
people's issues are
you know you you work together on them
you know and it's you kind of learn
where
uh you know people's like warts and
achilles heels are and and you just kind
of understand like okay this is you know
like like my my wife has a has like some
weird
[ __ ] from her childhood about like
cleaning and cleanliness and early in
our relationship we had a lot of really
dumb fights about stuff like that
because i'm just i'm i'm really messy
and then eventually you know we kind of
figured out like okay like this is this
is just her thing like this is
it was like her mom was kind of a psycho
about it and
there's some baggage there and so it's
like now we both understand like this is
a triggering area for her and so i know
i know to you know i i've adjusted my
lifestyle a little bit to kind of
accommodate that but she's also adjusted
a little bit and then it's like now when
something comes up we can actually talk
about it at like
a new level like we're no longer arguing
about
the counter space where like
we're having a discussion about like
where the threshold is that it starts
upsetting her and like what can we do
you know what habits can we develop as a
couple to like prevent that from
happening again proactive instead of
reactive
absolutely what do you think about the
concept i think i heard jordan peterson
say this that relationships are uh
are a decision
not a discovery i like that and and i
generally agree with it people talk
about commitment
and it's it's ultimately it's
commitment it's not you know
symbolically you know let's say you get
married or something like symbolically
that commitment is made once like you go
you have a wedding blah blah
but in reality it's like you're you're
recommitting
constantly you're like recommitting each
day in each moment and ideally you know
if if the relationship's good it's it's
a pleasure it's a joy to recommit daily
you know it's like you're excited you
know it's it's like
it's like working at a job that you love
like you you wake up excited to go to
work um
it's the same thing if your relationship
is good you're like excited to be
committed to that person like you're
actually excited to be spending time
with them
um
so in that sense it is a decision and
then when when
trouble spots arise and and issues come
up
you have to continue to make that
decision to keep working on it and and
and to keep going forward and so it's
yeah i mean ultimately people are uh
completely autonomous like you know and
it's if you're gonna be with somebody
for your your entire life you need to
consistently choose throughout your
entire life to be with them it's not
it's not just like oh [ __ ] i said i do
when i was 30. so i guess i'm stuck like
that's not that's not a healthy way to
look at it i think so do you think that
the reason why so many people divorce
and so many people split is because
essentially
one or both are not ready to look
deep deep enough at themselves to heal
things that will either make the
relationship better or make them realize
it's the wrong one
yeah i think people
go into marriage often with with
poor expectation like unrealistic
expectations i i think so here's
something i think is under discussed and
um
and i know you mentioned peterson like
peterson has a pretty strong view on
marriage
you know he says divorce is too easy
that
um
we should actually make it more
difficult to divorce and i mean i don't
know if i just agree or disagree with
that but i think one thing that that is
not talked about very often is that the
concept of marriage has evolved over the
past 100 years i mean it's actually
evolved throughout all of human history
it's been very different from century to
century but
especially the last hundred years or so
the concept of marriage has evolved
quite a bit and the expectations of
marriage have
evolved quite a bit so like i think
we we live in a society that is people
are way more independent than they were
say 50 years ago 60 years ago women in
particular are way more independent than
they were 50 60 years ago people are
more conscious about these issues
they're more aware of personal
development
uh
they're more aware of emotional issues
and baggage and trauma and all this
stuff which is great but it also
in a sense it kind of raises the bar
right because it's once you once you
become aware of all this stuff and
you're with a partner who's not
it becomes very very difficult to be
with that partner um
like you you either both need to be on
the personal development train or
neither but at the same time
are we still our society still has a lot
of kind of narratives around marriage
like kind of
unrealistic romantic narratives
uh
that
that maybe don't make sense anymore or
aren't as realistic as they were say a
hundred years ago such as
well i mean until death do us part i
mean
like
people [ __ ] live till their 40s
[Music]
i would be dying now yes yeah exactly so
like uh you know and there was a world
war like every 20 years and uh so he got
young at war all the time people died
from an infection
yeah so it's um
the standards have changed um but
meanwhile the narratives and and
kind of the romanticism has not and so i
think that's that's a little bit of a
it's created a mismatch and i think it's
gotten a lot of people into trouble um
you know one of the things that i've
kind of ardently written against
is um
like i'm constantly
just a wet blanket on
romantic love like i've written tons of
articles and
there's a section in subtle art about it
you know it's just like look romance is
great it's fun
you know but i actually wrote an article
i said you should treat romance like
alcohol like it's it's a lot of fun but
if you if you
if it's the only thing you want
all the time
uh it's gonna get messy like you're
gonna have like things somebody's gonna
get hurt
you know
is it that you can't keep it up or is it
that it's just a not a real it's not
real life
it's not real life and it skews
perception i mean this comes back to the
biases right so it it grossly skews your
perceptions of reality um it skews your
perceptions of the other person you
start believing that there's somebody
that they're not you start
uh assuming that they are going to love
you and do things for you that they are
not um
you know you
you assume things about your own life
that
are going to happen that that are not
you know so
romantic love it is
uh
the alcohol comparison was was done very
very consciously because it's
it's kind of like you know being
just absolutely
head over heels with somebody and
obsessed with them it's very akin to
being drunk like it feels good you're
having fun like it's a great time the
sex is going to be really good but
like you don't see straight yeah but
yeah you're not seeing straight and you
don't know you actually don't know who
you're going to wake up with in the
morning and there's the come down
exactly and so
at some point you're gonna hit that you
know you're gonna you're gonna wake up
and you're gonna look over and you'll be
like oh [ __ ] who is this like i don't
know this person you know um
so you have to be very careful with it i
mean romance is great but it's
the same way uh you know you don't want
to drink all day every day you know you
just want to drink on special occasions
and
you know maybe
you know friday night every now and then
or whatever like it's it's the same with
romance it's like your relationship
should not be based on romance romance
should be a nice little supplement for
the relationship so what's real life
then what is when you're when you're
when you're
addressing the idea of being in
partnership like what is real life as
opposed to thinking that it's this you
know we're going to be have so much fun
all the time we're always going to get
we're going to get along most of the
time we're going to you know it's it's
you know i feel like we've done so much
work and it's like there's going to be
tough times but like tough times get
re-freaking defined every time like you
think it's hard but like true growth
happens in the
really painful stuff and i don't just
mean like oh man that was a tough
decision but the [ __ ] that makes you cry
the [ __ ] that makes you go to a
therapist right
so what is a real what should be the
aspirational goals if you were making a
movie about the modern day relationship
and not the hollywood you know scene of
like you know they end up together in
the end and you know make out in the
rom-com
what does that movie look like i by the
way i'm the worst person to watch
rom-coms with because
all i do is just functional just
complain about how i'm like god this guy
is such he's so codependent this is
really unhealthy yeah
totally what an avoidance my wife is
just like shut up
just watch
uh hang on before we get into your
answer what is the best movie to see
like a just a sickly codependent
relationship like is there some red flag
movies that are like warning signs for
people that they could watch that would
be just like this is not real at all
this is a red flag this kind of
relationship doesn't exist dude so i i'm
trying to remember
so i i don't see rom-coms very usually
when i see a rom-com it's because i'm
you know
my wife's watching it and i'm i just get
sucked in um
i don't remember what it's called
there's one with drew barrymore and hugh
grant and he hugh grant was like uh i
think it was hugh grant but he was like
uh he was like uh used to be a rock star
he was like a one-hit wonder rock star
but it's like you know 10 20 years after
his career kind of ended um but he's
still kind of stuck in the past anyway i
forget what it was called but i think it
was him and drew barrymore
i ended up watching it and
i was horrified like hugh grant's
character it it's like
it's borderline stalking it you know he
like
gaslights her constantly
makes her think she's crazy like follows
her in the restaurants and stuff and
it's like it's treated as romantic i
think it was made in like the the
mid-2000s or something and uh you know
in the movies like oh this is so
romantic they're gonna end up together
and i'm like this is horrifying like
this is
this is like
yeah so anyway that i don't remember
what that was called but that one was
horrifying there there's actually a
great movie um
that came out last year called promising
young woman
um that was very much like a critique of
a lot of that kind of stuff like it was
really well done where it was kind of
it showed a lot a lot of the male
character i mean there's a lot of crazy
[ __ ]
that goes on in it too but there were a
lot of male there were male characters
in that movie that kind of behave like
kind of the classic
rom-com guys and so you spend half the
movie thinking like
oh he's a good guy he just he's in love
with her you know it's gonna be great
and then you know but the movie actually
shows how [ __ ] up it is and like how a
lot of the stuff that you think you're
being a good guy you think it you know
he's being romantic or whatever but it's
like it
it's not it's not healthy
basically don't watch rom-coms if you
want to understand how relationships
should go
yeah or or watch them as an example of
what not to do
like if a guy shows up in your front
yard with a boom box over his head like
shouting your name in the middle of the
night get away like just get away
[Music]
run the other direction got it
yeah no it's itself okay now we're
putting this into now we're
we're modern day humans we are we have
now decided that we need to look at our
childhood and our trauma and we want a
healthy relationship
what like what what does that look like
i mean yeah okay there's sprinklings of
romanticism of course right but then
there's
also like
practicality like how does real life
look with somebody
yeah
so i i
conceptualize this as kind of two
categories uh
i wrote an article about this
i got forever ago probably like
10 years ago um
so there's there's chemistry and there's
compatibility um
and chemistry is kind of like
it's the emotional personality side of
things so it's like you know you go to
dinner and you talk for four hours and
it feels like it was 30 minutes you know
it's like
somebody who gets you you you click
together you make each other laugh like
you kind of forget the times going by
like
it's the it's the experience that we all
look for and
it's a very important experience you
want to have that with with a romantic
partner
the problem is is that people mistake
chemistry for compatibility which is
what compatibility is is
similar values similar world view
similar life goals aspirations
um
and those are like the boring nuts and
bolts of a relationship that
are not super
sexy to talk about a lot of the time but
are
equally if not more important than
the chemistry stuff and
the classic mistake that people make is
is they find somebody they have tons of
chemistry with and
but they have no compatibility their
lives don't line up they've got huge
barriers to being together
they've got major major differences in
their their world views or what they
care about where they want who they want
to be
and
this causes a lot of friction and
the problem is is that friction can
actually make things feel more romantic
you know it becomes starts to become
kind of this like oh but you know we
love each other so we're going to find a
way and all this conquers all exactly so
like i i had a really good friend um
one of my my best friends from college
um
he is uh
his parents for he's indian and his
parents were from india and
um
you know he wasn't religious but he he
grew up in a hindu household and um was
not christian and all this stuff and
he met this was ages ago this was back
when we were in school but he met
uh like a
evangelical christian girl and they just
completely fell for each other
and
they had
nothing in common
she was hardcore like jesus 24 7. he was
like no jesus and you know by the way
like
my parents might even be a little bit
upset if they knew i was dating a white
girl like it was
it was just like nothing on paper
nothing made sense but it was almost
like that made it even more passionate
because
they were so into each other you know so
it's in the montagues yeah it's like
yeah it's a little scandalous you know
like
um and i remember talking and this kind
of comes back to to how
you know romance can blind you a little
bit make you drunk you know i remember
having
serious conversations with him where he
was like he's like you know i think we
can figure it out and i was like
uh
are you high like
have you seen who you're dating he's
like no no i think i really think we can
make this work i'm like you're crazy
dude like this is you're insane i'm like
look it was wonderful it felt great you
know but it's like this is not a
long-term thing people get so wrapped up
in the chemistry and the emotion and the
excitement and the romance that they
they neglect the compatibility things
and i would add to the compatibility
thing what we were talking about earlier
that two people who have both done kind
of the inner work
to
be capable of having a healthy
relationship like they've kind of gone
through their own [ __ ] um you know it's
like if you've got done that work and
the other person hasn't
they are not compatible with you like
it's it's like if you're willing to sit
down and kind of go line by line through
your childhood and trauma and stuff and
talk openly about it and they're not
it's not going to work like it's just
not yeah the openness and the the
ability to face those things
yeah it's probably i think it's
human nature to want to avoid them of
course
it it
sucks
it hurts
in your in your experience or opinion or
you know for yourself experience of
yourself or others
what
what does it really look like to
um
face those things and deal with those
things and i asked this because i like
just like going oh yeah i'm a jealous
person
i'm just jealous person like is that
enough like what does it really look
like to integrate that part of you and
to
to heal that aspect that feels that like
what's the what's that is should it be
ugly is should you see a therapist does
it take a long time is it just a
decision you make like what is that what
does that actually look like
and i've written about this a lot like
it doesn't really it's not really
happening unless it's painful
the the term you know vulnerability has
become very
popular the last 10 years renee brown's
kind of been the big proponent of it and
vulnerability is really important but i
think what i've noticed especially kind
of like the last four or five years is
that there's a lot of people who trick
themselves
by thinking that just because they're
disclosing something means they're being
vulnerable like i could i could tell you
ugly [ __ ] about my past but if i'm
telling you in a way that like i don't
really care what you think
and i don't really care
what happens uh it's not vulnerable
like by definition vulnerability
requires the potential for
hurt
yeah i look at it like from even myself
i've had to dig a little deeper at times
to
i think there's two scales like there's
a transparency scale and then there's
the vulnerability scale in my mind where
i'm a really really transparent person
you want to know something i'll tell you
but i try and practice
because i think brene brown said it that
real vulnerability is
admitting or telling some saying
something that you're not sure you're
ready to say
yep
yeah unless there's anxiety there it's
not
it's not legit
like there needs to be some internal
resistance
um which as a side note is it that's
kind of my barometer for good writing as
well like it's
like if i'm not nervous about publishing
something then it's probably not good
wow that's
that's amazing
because people could use that in their
own life in any way whether it's
something that they're writing a letter
that they're writing an email or a text
message or something they're ready to
say or whatever they can totally apply
that i i
wow what do you feel vulnerable about
right now like writing about or talking
about you know what's funny uh
i i've
for years i've kind of had this dream of
like writing fiction
but it's it's been you know it's one of
those dreams that like i i like
keep talking about it to people my
personal life but i never do it
and i started
dabbling maybe six months ago just like
writing out a few a few ideas and things
here or there
um
and it was a ton of fun and it was
really [ __ ] scary
and uh
and then i i there's a guy out here in
l.a named steven pressfield he wrote a
great book called the the war of art
um
he's an older guy he's been isn't there
a famous book called art of war too
right so yeah it's kind of a play on sun
tzu's book yeah so it's it's the war of
art because it's all about the creative
process and
the internal resistance that creators
artists have and the anxiety and the
self-doubt and stuff that you deal it's
a it's a brilliant book it's it's really
good um and he's
he's an amazing guy like he
worked in hollywood he was a
screenwriter in the 80s and 90s and uh
and then he wrote
started writing some fiction and then he
um
wrote a few non-fiction books the war of
art being one so
uh he's like 70 and he's
been through it all and uh i was having
breakfast with him and he was kind of
asking me the same question you know
he's like he's like what's exciting you
right now like what are you you know and
i kind of like listed all the projects
that are going on and mentioned the
wheel book or whatever
and then i got to the fiction thing and
i was like you know i'm kind of dabbling
in this and he's like he's like why
didn't you talk about that first i was
like well you know it just like it's
just this thing and i don't know if it's
going to be like he he just immediately
looked at me and was like i think you
should cancel all these other projects
and write fiction i was like what
it's like are you crazy
you know i started freaking out and it
but it's like it's that freak out that
that tells you you're on the right track
indicator because you're also excited i
can feel that energy like there's an
excitement around it but there's a fear
around it yeah so
what is that what is the fear then why
why why do we get scared to do things
that were are really calling us well
it's new
and it's um
you know
it's ironic this actually ties in really
well to kind of that thing we were
talking about with like transparency
versus vulnerability like
i've been writing self-help and personal
development for so long and i've been
writing about my own issues for so long
that it's actually my comfort zone you
know so like totally you know writing a
piece about you know some [ __ ] up
thing i did when i was 22. like to me
that's that's just home base like i
don't know how anxious i would feel
about that or how excited i would
actually feel about that
um
whereas fiction it's it's new it's a new
challenge i don't know if i'm good at it
or not um
and in some ways it's a little bit more
personal uh than non-fiction
because it's it is it's just pure idea
um and in non-fiction it's like if you
have a bad idea you can at least kind of
fall back on a cool story
or if you have a mediocre story you can
kind of fall back on like a really good
idea but in fiction it's like if if the
idea is bad
it the f it's just bad
like there's no escape you know um
you can't like yeah there's nothing to
kind of carry you through a weak chapter
sure you can't just say well it's my
life i'm sorry it's boring yeah
sorry
so we'll see i i that that's one thing
that i've kind of i want to do this year
is is play around with that is you know
um
sit down maybe
write out
100 pages or something and just see how
it goes see how it feels
see if i'm enjoying it seeing if i'm
still excited about it you are excited
about it clearly i am right now so
you're super excited yeah and you know
um is there is do you think it's because
when you write about
your own life
you
you know you can feel like the fact that
you've no recognize that in writing
about your own life and where you're at
it resonates with other people because
if you're there someone else is there
too but you're but with fiction you're
not sure that it will land at all
because it's just pure imagination
yeah
yeah it's it's no barometer like there's
no barometer there's no real life
barometer it's just an imagination
yeah and it's exactly and it's um
and you know with the personal
development stuff i've got
a 12-year track record and a huge
audience that's already built that
already wants to hear read it you know
like it's like i know there's already
demand for it
um
whereas you know with fiction there's a
real risk that it's like i write some
fiction i put it out there and then it's
you know my audience is just like dude
what the [ __ ] have you been doing the
last three years
you know where i can see this playing
into really well is that because i think
about um
i'm blanking on the name of the um the
the director for who did um inception
and
christopher nolan chris for nolan and so
when you see these movies they're
fiction right i mean this isn't a real
but there's you always wonder who wrote
that because they must be really [ __ ]
smart
yeah because and they really must have
some seriously deep thoughts and
experiences and things like that that
bring this stuff all to the table but
yet your art your your sort of your
you're putting it in the package of
of a movie of fiction um like i can see
that being something in your future
where you know this sort of fictitious
sort of stage merges with reality
because
we can't write about you probably i
don't know this is kind of an
interesting topic i mean can you
can you really you have to have
experienced or explored ideas in order
to even have the imagination for it i
think so
and i think that i think what you just
described is kind of the bridge that's
happening in my mind because
one thing i've noticed the last few
years
well first of all i've kind of just run
out of stories of my you know it's like
i've only lived so many years of life
and i've only screwed up so many times
um so
you know i've kind of run through
between
my books and hundreds of articles i've
kind of run through like
all the juicy stuff in my life for most
of it at least and so i've i've found
the last few years like it's kind of
hard to reach back and find something
that that really
i feel like is powerful or resonant i
mean there's you can only have so many
life-changing experiences so
you know
so it's funny because i i i found
actually when i was writing my last book
everything is [ __ ] like there's a
little bit of fiction in there there's a
little bit of historical fiction in
there and
because i i kind of just found like you
know what like this story kind of works
but it could work better and i know how
i can make it work better to explain
this point i want to make and so i was
just like all right let's just let's
take a stab at kind of embellishing it
and and running with it a little bit
and it was a ton of fun those were like
some of my favorite parts of that book
at a certain point like my own life is
is a limited canvas if i want to get a
larger canvas i need to kind of just
free myself to
invent characters and stories i have a
feeling you're gonna do that i have a
feeling you're gonna have a really fun
2022 with all kinds of cool information
coming through and stories and just you
know you're gonna i'm sure you're gonna
be able to see yourself in all of it all
right well thank you for your time i
could go on and on for days about
psychology and the human experience
people can just read your work because
at the end of the day you know as you
said there's only so much you can write
about and of course you run out of your
own stories because of how long you've
been alive but also there's only so many
approaches to fixing things and it's
just whether or not you [ __ ] do them
or you don't
exactly i just like to get as many
f-bombs in as possible for you
oh
i i've i've got plenty do you do you
want to drop some like you could no
[ __ ] given go for it okay yeah yeah
it's uh
just
just [ __ ] it yeah but yeah it's um you
know there's a reason why this stuff has
been written about for
thousands of years like it's because
humans don't change like
society changes technology changes
culture changes but
humans don't like the same [ __ ] that
help people
you know
2000 years ago
helps people today
and uh
and at a certain point you can't you can
only repackage it so many times true but
i think that
you know you're just i feel like you're
actually just going to use another
language to get to people
because there's no way your work doesn't
parlay into fiction and it's you can't
you're not making something up that
you've never thought of or experienced
um or read about and so
some people it's going to resonate more
just like some people read to understand
some people write to understand some
people watch things to understand
you know it's it and so maybe this is
going to come in the form you know this
will be just a different form of
communication with people that will get
to a new
group
that will understand it through story
last question then what's your what what
do you think is the first um
psychological
uh
psychological
lesson or
a story
that you would you would write about
um what fascinates you i guess the most
about psychology or what aspect of
psychology
in terms of like writing fiction like
what's kind of peaking my interest at
the moment so
one thing you know we've had all these
superhero movies the last 10 years right
and and i don't know about you but like
i got kind of burned out on them at a
certain point and one of the things that
frustrated me
as i watched them is i was like
some of these superpowers or some of
these like crazy scenes or whatever like
they would be
they would mess with these people's
heads so much like if you could
actually
you know have
telepathy or something like
that would [ __ ] with your identity and
sense of self to such a great extent it
would ruin relationships like you would
you could develop like
you could go on power trips like
you know coming back to that point of
like how our human perception is not
objective like it's it's malleable based
on our context and our relationships
um like when you insert something like
that into a person
i just think there's like a lot of
emotional and psychological
repercussions that are never explored in
any of these movies and so
one one area that i would love to play
with is just like
you know like what what's actually kind
of like a realistic
slash dark view of like how this stuff
affects people how how like a superpower
would affect somebody
and see just see where that goes just
see like see where it goes see if it's a
cool story see if it's an interesting
character
um
but like that's been like an itch that
i've had
for a few years now okay so then
another final question um take a
photographer just one more shot um so
then what superpower
as an insight
what superpower do you wish you had
oh do you think about the most
because i bet there's something there
like do you kind of wish you could read
people's minds do you wish you could fly
do you wish that you could just blow
people into an oblivion if they
wanted to with your hand right like
what would the superpower be that you
think about the most maybe not even one
but just think about
so the one i've thought about the most
is reading minds i actually think
if you could read people's minds it
would
very quickly
turn you into a narcissist
because you you would no longer like so
bringing it full circle talking about
intimacy
it's you know for intimacy to work
you have to there needs to be that that
anxiety of like you know what does she
think about me does she really like me
or like does she really believe me you
know like
there needs to be
kind of a veil of uncertainty there and
as soon as you lose that
and there's no anxiety around human
relationships
everybody just becomes very manipulable
like that that's kind of a textbook
definition of a narcissist is somebody
who sees
people
as something to manipulate for their own
pleasure i think about that a lot like
that would that would
absolutely destroy a person and then
they would probably destroy a lot of
other people around them have you ever
experienced a narcissistic relationship
yeah to a certain extent and i think
i've
been a little bit the narcissist in a
relationship
well you all you must know then that if
you admit or question whether or not
you're a narcissist you already really
probably aren't yeah but at the time i
never would have questioned that um
wow i mean this is a miracle because
the the experts would say you can't you
cannot heal from being a narcissist so
um
there's this is one of those areas that
that like gets really tricky so there's
there's narcissistic personality
disorder in pd which which that is
incurable and that's probably like
genetic based and it's like yeah those
people are just you know there's no
reaching them like they're just they
they're probably just incapable of
experiencing intimacy or empathy to a
certain extent whereas like just
narcissistic
trait like just
we all go through periods of more or
less narcissism of self selfishness self
absorption
um i i uh i went through a period in my
20s of very intense self-absorption and
narcissistic like behavior
um
as like a
a coping mechanism or like an
overreaction to
my previous [ __ ] i think this would be a
fascinating movie
i can't wait to see it
what's it called
oh god danica
making a movie okay we're making a movie
all right you're off the hook it's fine
um i'm a dreamer that's my problem is
that i feel like there are two kinds of
people there's people that live in the
future
and then there's people that live in the
past and when you're in the future i
feel like i have a little bit more of an
issue with attachment to things
attachment to outcomes
and but it makes me really dreamy like i
come up with companies all the time and
start them and i'm like oh now who's
gonna run it um
and then and then um the people that you
know i think live in the past are also
then they they kind of live with a
little bit more either anxiety or
sadness because you know it's not there
anymore or they're reliving the
experience that they didn't like
and um so i'm sorry that i inflicted my
dream on you no i know i love it i love
the attitude uh i i i just it's funny
because it's like i'm like an
early brainstorm and you're like yeah
what's gonna be called i'm just like
[ __ ] i don't know like slow down
i just i made this [ __ ] up like five
minutes ago
well thank you for freestyling with me
thank you for being vulnerable um
and
thank you for your time and i'm glad
that your work will continue
through uh all the mediums that you have
to continue to help because everybody's
on their own at their own stage in the
process and while you've moved on that
means that does not mean that everyone
is right there with you there are some
but there are lots of people that still
need the work and still need the lessons
and
thank you for sharing them
absolutely my pleasure thanks for having
me thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button